the expanse is a sci-fi show about
space politics action drama lasagna
and ancient alien mysteries it's set in
a future where humans have colonized the
solar system
earth is the big old political power run
by the united nations
mars is a rival superpower with advanced
technology and
military in the outer planets and the
asteroid belt
are the belters living on the dangerous
frontiers of space
belters have their own culture and
language and their bodies have adapted
to low gravity
but the resources and wealth of the belt
are still owned by the
inner planets earth and mars so a group
called the opa
fight for belter rights and independence
so tensions are high between earth mars
and the belt
and a single spark could cause war
in episode one holden works on a ship
called the canterbury
he used to be in the earth space navy
but now he's kind of slacking
and avoiding responsibility and taking
his shirt off a lot
naomi is an engineer from the belt she's
smart
and secretive about her past naomi is
close
with amos amos is weird he's
emotionally detached and can be brutally
violent
but he can also be friendly and loyal
and he tries to be
a good man amos has a mysterious past
involving
organized crime in baltimore alex is a
pilot from mars
he loves flying and cooks a mean space
lasagna
and he left a wife and child back on
mars
holden naomi amos and alex are the only
survivors
when the canterbury and then a martian
ship are both
mysteriously destroyed holden steps up
as a leader to protect his crew
they steal a martian warship and name it
rosinante
which is a reference to a story about a
foolish heroic knight
because holden's heroism is often
impulsive and
naive and sometimes does more harm than
good
naomi becomes his voice of reason
helping him make better choices
and they eventually start a relationship
the destruction of these ships
sparks conflict between earth mars and
the belt the martians blow up the moon
phoebe earth blows up the moon daimos
and the system
hurtles towards all-out war with the
help of opa leader fred johnson
the rossi crew investigate who started
this conflict
which leads them to eros and miller
miller is a washed up beatdown cynical
crooked cop
who doesn't really believe in anything
anymore
but he investigates the disappearance of
a girl called julie mao
he learns that she rejected a life of
wealth and privilege to fight for the
belt with the opa
she's tough and determined and selfless
and miller comes to love her
without ever having met her almost like
a religious faith
miller meets holden and the crew on eros
and together they find
julie dead infected with a mysterious
alien virus called the proto-molecule
it turns out that julie's father a
powerful businessman called jul pierre
is secretly experimenting with this
proto-molecule
he had the canterbury and the martian
chip destroyed to deliberately spark
war as a distraction so that he and his
scientists can
infect everyone on eros with the
proto-molecule
julie tried to stop him and just got
infected herself
so eros turns into a nightmare with this
alien contagion
and holden and miller work together to
escape their personalities clash
because holden's an idealist who
believes in peace
and truth and justice while the cynical
miller
uses deception and brutality to survive
they find dresden the scientist who
infected eros
and miller kills him on the spot holden
is
furious that miller would execute
someone in cold blood and
kicks him out of their crew but on eros
the protomolecule is
consuming the bodies and minds of
infected people
and seems to be building something
probably
something bad so the crew make a plan to
destroy eros
fred has this giant mormon spaceship
called the nauvoo
and they plan to slam it into eros to
knock it into the sun
but eros inexplicably dodges the ship
seeming to break the laws of physics and
its speeds towards earth
so miller goes into the heart of the
infected eros and finds
julie mao this infection spread
from her and her consciousness is part
of the proto-molecule
so he asks her to move eros away from
earth and to crash into venus
instead eros and julie and miller
disappear into the clouds
and earth is saved but while all these
heroics are happening
avasarala deals with the politics
avasarala is one of the most
powerful politicians in the government
of earth
in season one she's ruthless in fighting
opa terrorism
and martian aggression she tortures and
blackmails and
lies and betrays some of her friends
because she believes
that earth must come first and will do
anything to protect her home
and family but she discovers that the
conflict around eros wasn't caused by
the belt or mars
there's a conspiracy within her own
government on earth
working with jul pierre mao to
deliberately cause war and use the
protomolecule
as a weapon avasarala gets help
from bobby bobby is a martian marine
a powerful soldier loyal to mars at
first
she wants war with earth but on ganymede
her squad gets wiped out by a monstrous
proto-molecule creature
and she discovers that her own
government was behind this
jul pierre secretly works with mars as
well as earth
to weaponize the proto-molecule his
scientists experiment on children
transforming them into these hybrid
proto-molecule
killing machines so bobby leaves the
martians and goes all iron
man to defend other sarala and works
with the rosie crew to fight the
conspiracy
these people from earth mars and the
belt settle their differences
and come together as a team amos makes
friends with a botanist called prax
and helps him save his daughter naomi
and alex save
mars from proto-molecule missiles bobby
kills a hybrid to avenge her squad
and holden arrests julpier mao
the evil conspiracy is ended
but on venus the proto-molecule has been
busy
when a science ship investigates the
proto-molecule disassembles their ship
and poor adam savage asphyxiates the
proto-molecule
is intelligent and powerful and
purposeful
in season three it emerges from venus
and forms a mysterious
ring which seems to be like a wormhole
so earth and mars on the belt send ships
to investigate
including the rocinante holden and the
crew are getting sued by mars
for stealing their ship so a journalist
called monica pays their legal fees and
in return she films them for a
documentary
but naomi isn't with them she loves
holden
amos and alex but she also loves her
people
the belters so she joins her friend
drummer
on the opa ship behemoth the behemoth
was originally the nauvoo
the giant mormon spaceship but after it
was launched at eros
fred and drummer converted it into a
giant opa
warship it represents the hope for a
belter nation
and of the opa as a real political power
drummer captains the behemoth at the
ring
but she has to contend with ashford an
opa pirate who would rather control the
ship himself
and there's a greater threat from
clarissa mao
clarissa is the eldest daughter of
julpier mao the businessman behind the
protomolecule conspiracy
when her father is jailed and shamed for
his crimes
clarissa wants revenge on holden so she
flies to the ring as a maintenance
worker and she
blows up a ship and uses like a deep
fake video
to frame holden for her crime the
behemoth attacks the rosie so they have
to escape
into the ring and inside the ring is a
mysterious space where
an alien force prevents anything from
going
above a certain speed this prevents
ships from attacking each other
or damaging the ring and holden has
weird visions of miller miller
died when eros crashed into venus but
the protomolecule
incorporated miller's consciousness into
itself and uses him to communicate with
holden
this ghostly miller leads holden to a
mysterious station
at the center of the ring and there
holden has visions of the ancient past
he learns that the ring was built by a
powerful alien civilization
called the builders the builders created
the proto-molecule
not as a weapon but as a tool to build
these ring gates
but aeons ago the builders were
destroyed by some
mysterious other aliens this
ghost of miller is the builder's
technology trying to learn
what happened to its creators some
martians attack
holden and the ring sees them as a
threat so it suddenly
lowers the speed limit instantly
decelerating all the ships in the space
which kills or injures thousands
drummer and ashford get trapped under a
tractor
they spend some quality time and squash
their beef
and their legs but naomi builds drama
some robot legs so it's all good
but all these injured people are a
disaster
because ships in the expanse create
gravity by constantly accelerating with
their thrusters
it's like how you're pushed back in your
seat when you accelerate a car
but they accelerate constantly with the
ring's speed limit they can't accelerate
to make gravity
which means the injured people can't
heal because blood
doesn't drain right in 0g but the
behemoth
has another way to make gravity it can
spin
creating gravity by centrifugal force so
ashford invites all the injured earthers
and martians to the behemoth to heal
it's a show of strength and compassion
and reconciliation
from the new belter nation naomi returns
to the rossanante
because she's loyal to the belters but
the rosie crew
are a family clarissa tries to kill
holden and attacks naomi but she's saved
by
anna anna is a pastor and on the ring
she offers
compassion and comfort to the scared and
injured
she offers some guidance to amos and
helps convince clarissa to
cool it with all the murdering and to
seek redemption instead
everyone's still stuck in the ring space
so ashford tries destroying the ring
the ring gets fed up with humanity and
starts charging its weapons to wipe out
the entire solar system like a bloody
halo ring
holden has a better plan and fights
ashford's men for control of the
behemoth
with the heroism of the rosy crew
drummer bobby
anna and even clarissa they defeat
ashford and they shut down
all their ships to show the ring that
they're not a threat
the ring then chills out and reveals its
true purpose
it opens a thousand new gates wormholes
to distant star systems with habitable
worlds
these are thousands of new opportunities
for land and resources
and freedom so in season four humanity
ventures into new worlds
earth mars and the belt are at peace and
avasarala becomes the secretary-general
of the united nations
governing earth some belters go through
the ring and settle a planet called
illus
where they discover some mysterious
alien
proto-molecule-looking structures so
holden and the crew
investigate they land on the alien
planet and naomi
walks under a sky for the first time as
a belter she grew up in low gravity
so this planet is hell on her body so
she and alex stay
in the rosie in orbit on illus holden
tries to make
peace between the belter settlers and an
earth corporation who want the planet
for themselves
their leader mercury kills some belters
and calls them
terrorists he's a brute but he's not
all wrong some of the belters do blow up
a ship full of people
in their desperation to keep their new
home
holden investigates the alien structures
the
ghost of miller leads him to reactivate
some billion-year-old alien machinery
which malfunctions and explodes sending
a massive
tidal wave at their settlement and
disabling their ships
they take cover in one of the structures
but it's full of deadly alien
slugs and everyone except holden goes
blind from an infection
and they're running out of food it's a
really shitty time
so miller guides holden to a mysterious
ancient weapon billions of years ago the
builders who created these structures
and rings and the proto-molecule
were destroyed by some other aliens
using
these weapons miller puts himself into a
body
and steps into the weapon to disable all
the alien tech
on the planet and to destroy himself
so the tortured ghost of miller is
finally put to rest
and the planet is safe holden has a
western showdown with mercury and
captures him
rejecting his lawless brutal wild west
ethos in favor of peace
justice and due process amos
has a relationship with one of mercury's
soldiers and she forces him to choose
between her and mercury
or the rosie crew and he chooses the
rosie
alex and naomi pull some smart moves to
keep their ships in the air including
using
a railgun as a thruster they protect a
belter who was a terrorist but was nice
about it
and they leave a scientist called elvi
to study the remaining
alien artifacts so the crew save illus
but this alien technology remains a
mystery
on earth other fights a political battle
she is challenged in an election by a
rival nancy gao
and avasarala pulls some dirty tricks to
try and win
she leaks and lies and orders a military
strike that ends up killing civilians
in the end avasarala loses the election
and her husband
arjun leaves because she put politics
and pride
ahead of her morals and her family
without arjun
and without her power who is of asarala
now
on mars bobby gets kicked out of the
military for
constantly disobeying orders to go save
the world and
life on mars is kind of depressing now
martians had worked together for
generations to terraform the red planet
into a habitable world
but now that there are thousands of
already habitable planets beyond the
ring
mars is kind of pointless people leave
bobby had believed in the martian dream
but now that dream
is dying and her new boyfriend who buys
her waffles leaves as well
so bobby gets involved with some
criminals who steal martian technology
and sell it on the black market
it seems harmless at first but she
discovers that it's linked to a
dangerous conspiracy
in the ring the opa ship behemoth is
renamed to medina station
it's the hub of a new belta nation and
the gateway to the worlds beyond the
ring
it's run by ashford and drummer and they
learn that
peace is hard they try to cooperate with
earth and mars but
many belters still hate the inner
planets there are attacks by a belter
extremist called marco inaros
back in the day naomi had a son with
marco called philip
naomi left marco because he didn't want
to be involved in marco's terrorism
and naomi hasn't seen her son since
ashford attacks marco but gets spaced
and the old pirate goes out singing
marco believes that peace between the
belters and the inner planets
is impossible and they need to fight for
their future
so marco plans a terrible attack using
bobby's stolen martian technology
he gets an asteroid and paints it with
martian stealth tech
and launches it towards earth this could
kill
billions of people and with the stealth
tech
they won't see it coming so
will earth be saved will bobby uncover
a martian conspiracy will naomi reunite
with marco and philip
will alex and amos make peace with their
pasts
will holden discover the mysteries of
the alien builders and the mystery of
how to keep his shirt on
season 5 episode 1 is out now and we've
made a video about it that you can watch
at the link below
it's on the amazon prime video uk
youtube channel because they sponsored
this video
so check out the video subscribe to
their channel and if you want more
expanse videos comment below
thank you to our patrons including anton
labonets only raw nicole candelaria
eddie millen cliff w
and plasman cheers
you